the last son of the doomed planet
Krypton Superman defends Earth while
fighting for truth and justice kal-el is
a powerful bruiser who excels at
initiating and finishing team fights his
passive is Man of Steel after dealing
damage with a skill Superman gains a
shield for a short time after gaining
the shield each of his other skills can
increase the shield's power Kryptonian
Mike gives your next basic attack
additional attack damage you have it has
a maximum of two charges and using it
consumes a charge use frost breath to
exhale a frosty cone of power damage
that slows enemies for a short time
heat vision fires a targeted energy
blast at your enemies dealing power
damage and knocking them back you have
defeated enemy your target is also
revealed and using heat vision again
causes Superman to dash to your target
Superman's ultimate is speeding bullet
he flies directly to a targeted enemy
and strikes them and nearby enemies for
attack damage
he can be intercepted by other enemy
champions while in flight but is immune
to disables Superman's heat vision and
frost breath give a good amount of crowd
control allowing you to lock down enemy
champions remember that man of steel
only lasts for a short time after
dealing skill-based damage so to
maximize its benefit get into fights
quickly and deal damage while all your
skills are up you have fainted an enemy
speeding bullet is a great way to
initiate or chase down fleeing enemies
you have an enemy after landing your
ultimate a well-placed frost breath will
slow your target use this moment to
reposition and blast the target with
heat vision doing your best to push them
towards your team starting with nil
weapon and tektite vial will provide
immediate damage and lane sustained when
you're back at base an early crime Bible
helps to build stacks of health
useful artifacts include Joe chills
revolver for its attack damage
huntresses crossbow for its cooldown
reduction and Lobos chain for the health
and passes when looking for defense
metallus heart provides attack armor and
extra will in for power armor consider
spear of destiny as its passive grants
additional attack damage for a
percentage of your total health
Superman's super strength provides more
attack damage while on cooldown making
it beneficial to always start fights by
throwing cars and meteors lead your
allies to victory as Superman the last
son of krypton